Right. Hi, everyone. So,
thank you to everyone who came to our session,
and I'll be very, very brief. The session, as you can
see, is about AI and
the meeting point between AI and spatial transcriptomics,
to see if and to what extent we can predict spatial gene
expression
or any other interesting things that
one can think of predicting directly from the
histopathology slides. And we will have
three talks.
The first two talks will be by two
amazing superstar scientists
in this bridging field of AI, computational
biology, and spatial transcriptomics.
The first speaker will be Mingyao Li, Dr.
Mingyao Li from UPenn. I'm sure many of
you are aware of her cutting-edge
work. The second speaker is James Zou
from Stanford. A
general AI leader and so on, but James
regrettably is under the weather, but we have his talk
recorded. Then the third speaker will be
myself. And after that,
Mingyao and me, we will be happy to take questions and have
discussion. Also, if you can see the
barcode, or how is it called? I don't know.
The thing, the QR thing. You can scan
it, and then you can
put questions into that link,
and presumably, I'm supposed to see them
somewhere and answer. But if not, just raise your hand
because I'm technologically challenged. Okay, guys?
So without further ado, we will hopefully start on
time.
Dr. Li, please. Looking forward to your talk.
Thank you so much for the very kind introduction, and thank you for the
invitation. It's a great pleasure to be here.
So today, I'm going to share our recent work on digital tissue twins,
and in particular, how to turn histology into spatial omics at the population
scale.
Spatial omics technologies, including spatial transcriptomics and
spatial proteomics, have transformed our understanding of tumor
ecosystems. However, despite their power, the
current spatial technologies remain expensive and slow,
and this makes them difficult to scale across the full clinical
enterprise.
So for example, just mounting a small piece of tissue can easily cost you
a few thousand dollars. But on the other hand, many of the
spatial omics platforms allow the generation of a histology image from the
same tissue slice. And oftentimes, these histology images are
very high resolution, high quality, and importantly, these
histology images are very inexpensive, and indeed, they are already
routinely being generated for nearly every cancer patient in the
clinic.
So this highlights a fundamental data tradeoff issue in spatial
biology. On one hand, spatial omics is molecular
information-rich but is expensive and slow, difficult to
scale.
On the other hand, digital pathology is common, cheap, and fast, but
contains no molecular information.
So a central question that the field is facing right now is: how can we
bridge this gap?
And this central question has motivated our development of what I
call the digital tissue twins, where our goal is to transform
those routine H&E slides into spatially resolved and
molecularly informed digital representation of human tissues at the
population scale so that we can link spatial biology,
AI, and clinical outcomes together to enable risk
prediction, patient stratification, and eventually
therapeutic decision-making.
So in the last few years, my lab has been developing this AI-powered
ecosystem to help us build what I call the digital tissue twins.
In this ecosystem, we start from H&E stained
histology images. We have developed the tools that can conduct the
H&E QC and the cellular resolution tissue masking,
and the cellular resolution histopathology image segmentation.
And leveraging these processed histology images, we also have developed
tools that can help researchers to automatically select the
most informative samples and the regions of interest for the
expensive spatial omics experiments.
And after the spatial omics data are generated, we can further leverage these
histology images to enhance the quality of the spatial omics data.
And after all of this data preparation is being done, we will build AI
models to virtually predict the spatial omics data at the
population scale. In the meantime, we also perform multi-modal
data integration so that we can have a comprehensive
representation of every single tissue section in every single
patient.
And throughout this inference and integration process, we use
rigorous statistical modeling to ensure that the AI models that
we build are reliable and are trustworthy.
So the core idea behind building digital tissue twins is teaching
AI to see molecules within a histology image.
And this is based on a simple but powerful observation that is
similar histology implies a similar molecular profile.
So this means that if we can ask the AI to learn this link,
then the histology images can become proxies of the spatial
molecular marvelous that people typically obtain in the expensive
spatial omics experiment.
So our work in this space started back in 2021.
We were among the first to treat the histology as a primary modality in
spatial omics analysis.And then later we developed the
iSTAR, where we used a hierarchical vision transformer to extract
image features out of a histology image.
And this mimics how a pathologist examines a histology slide under the
microscope.
And after the image features are extracted, we further leverage these
image features to enhance the spatial resolution of gene expression
data to single cell level. So for example,
medium does not provide a single cell resolution gene expression.
By using iSTAR, we can spatially enhance the resolution to single
cell level. So importantly, iSTAR demonstrated
that we can now turn a routinely obtained H&E slide into
single cell resolution spatial omics profiles.
And building upon the success of iSTAR, we later developed the
iSCALE, which utilized the virtual prediction idea
to scale up spatial transcriptomics for larger sized tissues that
far exceed the capture areas of conventional spatial omics platforms.
And this framework is generic. It can be applied to any tissue types
of any size as long as you can measure a H&E stained histology
image. So basically, by doing this innovative computational
analysis, we can turn a task that is experimentally impossible
into something that is computationally feasible.
So last year, we further leveraged the relationship between tissue
morphology and molecular profiles to develop this new tool
called i2Omics, where we wanted to use AI to assist
biologists to automatically select the most informative regions of
interest for the expensive spatial omics experiments.
So by doing so, we ensure that you can target
your expensive spatial omics experiment to the biologically most
important tissue area.
And since the development of these methods, my lab has been continuing trying
to push the field forward. Where our eventual goal is to turn
histology slides into single cell resolution spatial maps at the
population scale.
But when predicting gene expression directly from histology images, we're
facing a fundamental challenge. The challenge is that the gene expression is
highly dynamic. The dynamic range can substantially vary from one
person to the other. So when we directly predict a gene expression
from histology images alone, we don't really know the relevant
ranks of the dynamic ranges across the different people we are trying to
predict. And this leads to two fundamental issues that we have to consider.
The first issue is that when we do gene expression prediction at the population
scale, we wanted to make sure that the predicted gene expression magnitudes are
comparable across the different people we are predicting.
But if you only have the histology images as input, this dynamic range
is not available. The second risk is that when you only use
the histology images as input, you are risking the possibility of generating
a lot of false positive predictions.
And this is an issue that none of the existing methods that are addressing or
even talk about. But I think in order to apply these virtual predictions
in the clinical applications, it's very important to ensure that we are
reducing the false positive predictions from all of these AI
models. So to solve this question, we asked, "What if
we just provided the AI models a little bit of extra information, such
that the AI knows the relevant ranks of the dynamic ranges that
we are trying to predict?" It turns out bulk RNA-seq, which is
very inexpensive to obtain, can exactly provide this information we need.
And this motivated us to develop this AURORA model, where we
utilize bulk RNA-seq data as a constraint for the AI models
when doing the predictions. And in this process, we are trying to mimic
how a human look at a histology slide.
We gradually zoom into the tissue, and we progressively enhance the
spatial resolution of the gene expression prediction we make until we reach
to the final single cell resolution.
And throughout this process, we also generate cell type predictions at
every location we examine. So by the end of this analysis,
we are able to give you a single cell resolution spatial map that has a single
cell resolution spatial gene expression data across the whole transcriptome.
And we are also able to give you the cell type information at every
single location in the tissue of interest.
So now let me show you some of the evaluations that we have.
So in order to establish the reliability of AURORA, we need to
compare the predicted values versus the ground truth.
So in this analysis, we leverage the high quality spatial gene
expression data generated by my wonderful collaborators, Dr.
Houmam Akhdar and Lihua Wang's labs at MD Anderson.
So in this dataset, we have utilized twenty-three
lung adenocarcinoma patients, and we have the
medium gene expression data generated from all of them.
We spatially enhanced the resolution of this data into single cell level
by iSTAR. And in this analysis, we trained our virtual
prediction model using eighteen of the samples, and we virtually
predicted the gene expression to the remaining five.
And this allowed us to compare the predicted values and the
directly measured values in the original experiment.
And the lung tissue is particularly interesting, because in the lung tissue, there
is a lot of airspace. If you see positive predictions in the
airspace location, it means that you have false positive predictions.
So this dataset allows us to evaluate not only the Pearson correlation
between the predicted and the observed, but also allowed us to
evaluate the degree of false positive predictions.
So looking at the top right corner of the plot, you
can see that among all of the methods that we compared to, AURORA
achieved the highest Pearson correlation and the lowest false positive
rate. In contrast, many of the state-of-the-art methods that are
available out there, they generate false positive predictions.
So now let me show you how a false positive prediction looks like.
So in this tissue slide, you can see that we have a pathologist annotated blood
vessels, and at the bottom left, you can see the ground truth
measurement of gene MTH11.And if you compare the
predictions of different approaches with the ground truth, you can see that
AURORA achieved a high correlation and a very low false positive rate.
In contrast, two of the top competing methods, they generated a lot of
false positive signals. So this is just one of the many genes that we predicted.
In reality, if you wanted to utilize these AI models in the clinical
applications, you need to ensure that your predictions are reliable, you
are not simply predicting false positives.
So now after establishing the reliability of AURORA, we
next applied AURORA to generate the single-cell resolution spatial
maps on population cohort studies.
And here we utilized the data produced by
TCGA, and we virtually predicted a single-cell resolution spatial
maps on nearly 4,000 TCGA samples across different tumor
types. And in this talk, I'm going to focus on lung
adenocarcinoma, and we applied our virtual prediction model
trained on 18 medium samples
to this TCGA cohort. So in total, we predicted
885 TCGA lung adenocarcinoma slides.
And at the bottom, you can see one of the tissue samples that we predicted.
Although we don't really know the ground truth in TCGA, but we do know the
underlying pathology. So if you look at the KRT8 expression
that we predicted, you can see that the predicted expression pattern agreed
very well with the known tumor pathology.
So the real value of virtual prediction at the population scale lies
in the possibility to identify important and clinically
relevant spatial biomarkers for cancer.
So to this end, we conducted a tumor spatial niche
discovery. We utilized the cellular composition information
we inferred from AURORA to do this tumor microenvironment
analysis, and we identified quite a few interesting spatial
biomarkers. So for example, we were able to detect
TLS, which is well known to play an important role in antitumor
response. And due to the high-resolution information we predict,
we can also classify the TLS into early stage TLS
and mature stage TLS. And we can further utilize the mature
TLS that we identified to stratify the patients according to the areas of
the mature TLS. And interestingly, we found that those patients
that have a larger area of mature TLS, they tend to have
a better survival.
So after seeing this, we then asked a deeper question.
We wanted to ask, does the location matter?
So in this analysis, we looked at the co-localization between tumor
and the TLS, and we found out that those patients that have higher
degree of co-localization between tumor and the TLS, they tend to have
better cancer survival. So this example demonstrated that
by doing virtual predictions, we can even recover higher-order
spatial structure in the tumor samples.
And another interesting spatial biomarker we recovered in this
analysis is what I call the spatial cuff.
And in fact, this type of structure was first reported in the
"Cancer Cell" paper by Dr. Linghua Wang's group.
So in this paper,
Dr. Linghua Wang's group conducted a very sophisticated interesting spatial
analysis utilizing single-cell resolution spatial omics data
generated from Xenium, CosMx, Merscope MC, and
CODEX. And they discovered this structure called the
Eisman cuff, where you can see that you have the tumor cells in the center, and
they are surrounded by the cuffs. And this type of structure is conserved
across different tumor types. And more importantly, this
type of a spatial cuff leads to poor prognosis.
So if you look at the top plot, you can see that using
AURORA, we are able to recover and recapitulate this type of a
spatial cuff pattern, and we further stratify our patients in the
TCGA cohort according to how much this spatial cuff they
possess. And we see that patients that have a higher degree of this
spatial cuff tends to have a lower survival
outcome. So this example demonstrated that those findings
that you obtain from the expensive single-cell resolution spatial
omics experiments can be recovered, recapitulated using this
virtual prediction concept.
So while transcriptomics is informative and powerful, but we know that
biology is more than RNA. So in order to have a full picture of the tissue
that we study, we need to understand the other omic
modalities. So to solve this question, we recently developed a
tool called MISL, which allowed us to simultaneously
model multiple omic modalities together with histology image
information for very high-resolution tissue segmentation.
And using MISL, we were able to detect a very small structure called the
high endothelial venule in the TLS automatically.
Although MISL is powerful,
currently it's only limited to the analysis of one single tissue
section. But nowadays, in the real-world applications, we
often see diverse spatial omics datasets
generated from different tissue sections, either coming from the same patients
or coming from diverse patients. And ideally, we wanted to
have a technology that is able to simultaneously measure all
of the potential omic modalities on the same tissue size.
But realistically, this is almost impossible because as you're adding
additional omic modalities onto the same tissue size, you cannot avoid to
destroy the sample, meaning that the quality of the data you'll get is
going to be degraded. So in order to solve this challenge, we
recently developed another tool called Old Cozy, which allows us
to use a sophisticated graph-based approach to integrate
fragmented spatial omics data to virtually reconstruct what I
call the complete spatial omics. So the goal is that by the end
of this integration, we can do this virtual prediction and virtually predict
missing omic modalities, meaning that we can turn a task that
is experimentally impossible into something that is computationally
feasibleSo to demonstrate the power of COZEE, let me show
you an application again to this lung cancer study.
So in this analysis, we virtually integrated
three million cells obtained from four lung
adenocarcinoma patients. And you can see that the first two patients,
they have a histology image measure.
They also have a whole transcriptomic gene expression.
And the third patient has a histology image and the proteins.
And the fourth patient only has a histology image information available.
And by doing this integration and computational virtual
prediction, we are able to identify a small cluster
that is corresponding to macrophages.
And the reason that we are able to infer that this cluster is corresponding to
macrophages is because we're able to leverage the molecular information
provided by the previous three samples.
So after we identified the macrophages on patient four using their
HE as input only, we visualized our results
together with our pathologist collaborator, and the pathologist confirmed
that the cluster we identified in patient four indeed
corresponding to macrophages.
So here are the virtual predictions we produced.
You can see that our virtually predicted spatial gene expression profiles and the
protein expression profiles agreed with the direct measurements very
well.
And using COZEE, we can further integrate data in the 3D context.
So suppose you have zero tissue sections generated from a
3D tumor block, but in reality, it's very possible that you use different
spatial omics technologies using different tissue sections.
So using COZEE, we're able to integrate everything together into the same space.
And now you can visualize the multi-omic information in the real
3D tumor volume, and you can see some structures that
cannot be seen while you study the tissue sections in 2D.
So, for example, we were able to visualize the complex
TIAs network, and in addition, you can study the
spatial relationship between blood vessels and the
tumor. And in this analysis, in fact, we did
very, very comprehensive evaluations.
We considered almost all of the possible omic modalities, ranging from
histone modifications to chromatin accessibility, gene expression,
and protein abundance, and metabolites.
And we also considered almost all of the possible existing commercialized
spatial omics platforms out there, and we also considered many different
tissue types and disease contexts.
If you want to learn more about COZEE, you are welcome to read our recent archive
paper.
So to scale up this biological insight to the
broader field, we recently developed the Foundation model.
So here, we utilized the rich dataset produced by Dr.
Kadaris and Dr. Wong's labs. And we build our
Foundation model using 36 million cells
generated from 54 tissue sections.
And in this dataset, we have a rich spatial
annotation information obtained by the pathologist, and we also
have whole transcriptomic gene expression data.
We also have protein expression data across 35 proteins.
So by building this Foundation model, now the research community can simply
fit in your data into our Foundation model, and we are able to give you
comprehensive multi-modal information at a single-cell resolution.
We're able to give you the pathologist annotation.
We're able to give you the whole transcriptomic gene expression information.
We're able to give you the whole 35 protein spatial
proteomics information, all at the single-cell resolution level.
So now let me show you the application to the TCCCA cohort using COZEE
Foundation. So you can see that by applying the histology images
in the TCCCA cohort into COZEE Foundation, we're now able to
transfer the pathologist annotation in our training
dataset onto TCCCA. So now we have the annotation available.
Additionally, we are able to produce a whole transcript from spatial gene
expression and the protein expression for 35 proteins at a single-cell
resolution. And because the resolution is so high, this allows us
to automatically detect the tumor boundary.
So here are four representative samples in the TCCCA.
You can see that the boundary we detected is very fine-grained, and this
analysis is very fast. Imagine if you ask a pathologist to manually annotate the
tumor boundary in the TCCCA cohort, how long that is going to take.
And this analysis is totally unsupervised. It's super fast.
And this tumor boundary analysis further allowed us to conduct a tumor
interface analysis. So, for example, we can look at the cell type
compositions along the tumor edge, and we found that
those samples that have a higher proportion of lymphocytes along the tumor
edge, they tend to have a better survival.
And furthermore, we conducted this spatial gradient analysis.
We looked from the tumor edge into the tumor core, and we gradually
examined the proportions of lymphocytes from the tumor edge
down to the tumor core. And this allowed us to examine which patients
have a higher degree of lymphocyte infiltration as compared to the
other. And interestingly, we found out that those patients that have a
higher degree of lymphocyte infiltration into the tumor core,
they tend to have a better cancer survival.
So, so far I have demonstrated that virtual predictions can
help us produce a population scale spatial omics datasets,
and this can allow us to automatically detect the tumor boundary, tumor edge,
tumor interface, et cetera, and can help us identify potential
spatial biomarkers. But in order to utilize these virtual prediction
tools in the clinical setting, we wanted to make sure that the results we
produce are reliable. And the clinicians need to know where the model is certain,
where the model is just simply guessing.
So in order to address this real challenge, we developed another
tool called Utopia, where we wanted to use principle statistical
approaches to help people understand why we are
confident about our virtual predictionsSo Utopia is
based on a statistical technique called conformal learning, which means that
our model, our approach, is a prediction model
agnostic, meaning that this approach can be applied
to any virtual prediction models.
And using Utopia, we can give you a statistically calibrated
confidence score
depending on the spatial resolution you are considering and depending on the
biological target you are predicting.
So here we consider the different spatial resolutions ranging from lower
resolution to higher single-cell resolution, and we also consider the
different biological entities that we predict, ranging from a single
gene to a meta-gene, from by the combination of multiple genes,
and from a specific cell type to a more broadly defined cell class.
So here I want to show you a real-world application.
So in this analysis, we focused on the virtual prediction problem in
a sample that has gastric cancer. We built our
virtual prediction model using the molecular information obtained from
the two red boxes, the regions of interest we selected.
And after we built our virtual prediction model, we applied this virtual prediction
model to the rest of the tissue, only using the underlying historic image
information as input. So now you can see that across
the different spatial resolutions that we predict, lower resolutions are
much easier
to obtain a higher confidence than a higher resolution.
This makes a lot of sense. And we also see that predicting a single gene like
CD4 is a much harder task than predicting a meta-gene like a
TIS signature. And we also found that a continuous variable,
so the gene expression, is much harder to predict than a categorical
variable like a cell type. So basically, by doing this
analysis, we are able to give you a principle, a statistical
framework that can tell you where your virtual predictions are reliable,
where your virtual predictions are not reliable.
So this means that when we utilize virtual predictions in the clinical setting,
we know where is the tissue region that we should conduct
the real spatial omics experiment.
So to summarize, spatial omics is a powerful technology, but
currently, spatial omics is still too expensive to scale up in the
real-world applications. And in this talk, I have demonstrated
to you that by using innovative AI tools, we can now
turn histopathology data into digital tissue twins, where
every H&E slide can now become a spatially
resolved and molecularly informed tissue map.
And this allows us to scale spatial omics across
diverse patient populations, and the resulting data will enable
us to do risk prediction, patient stratification, and also allows
us to bridge spatial biology, AI, and
therapeutic decision making together.
So before I finish, I wanted to thank the following members of my lab
who did much of the work I presented today.
I also wanted to thank my wonderful collaborators and my funding support.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Happy to take questions. Yeah.
Please, questions at the end.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for this amazing talk.
And could you please put on the James Xu's
recording? Thank you.
Hi, everyone. I apologize that I'm not able to attend AACR in
person this year, but I'm happy to
present some of the work we've been doing around generative and agentic
AI for spatial omics.
So this presentation will have two parts.
In the first part, I want to present this AI method that we developed called
Rosie, which is an approach to generate in
silico spatial proteomic images from H&E.
In the second part, I want to explore some of the applications in using these
kind of spatial and other single-cell omics data to
accelerate therapeutic development.
And we'll do this with AI agents, with the virtual biotech.
So there's been tremendous interest in generating very rich
spatial omics information from tissue samples,
and
spatial proteomics that leverages multiplex
immunofluorescence imaging has emerged as a particularly promising
approach. So methods like Codex can simultaneously
image 50 to 100 different protein markers in
parallel on the same tissue sections.
And this enables us then to be able to phenotype many more different cell types
at higher resolution, and also be able to understand some of
the better tumor microenvironments and cell-cell interactions.
However, generating such high dimensional single-cell
spatial omics data is quite
expensive, right? So here's sort of a comparison across different
methods. So with H&E images, the molecular information we collect is
relatively sparse. It's mostly capturing morphologies, but the benefit
is that it's very
cheap and also can be collected in a few hours.
However, if we move towards this highly multiplexed immunofluorescence
imaging like Codex, which is now able to capture at
single-cell resolution, 50 plus different biomarkers,
but the cost is much more expensive, can be thousands of dollars per
slide and also takes multiple days to collect.
So there's this really several orders of magnitude increase in cost and
complexity when we go from H&E to this highly multiplexed
spatial proteomics.So our goal here
is to see, can we actually use
this H&E kind of images to help us to generate in
silico CODEX, in silico spatial omics?
And this is analogous in some ways to the ability of AI to try to
colorize black and white images into these more vivid
colors. Right, so in our case, we view the H&E image as sort
of analogous to these black and white images, and we
want to essentially use AI to add these different colors to it so that it looks
more like this very rich kind of spatial omics, like a
CODEX data.
In order to do this, we need to build a trainer model that can impute
CODEX
proteomics data from H&E images. And this
requires collecting a large paired data set where we have both H&E
images and CODEX measurements that are measured on the exact same tissue
sections.
So to do this, we collaborated with our collaborators at
Enable Medicine, and we generated, at the time, the largest paired H&E
and CODEX data sets. So this is the data set we collected for ROSI,
which has over 2,000 samples covering 30 million
cells from 16 different disease types.
And this is all done at sort of a high resolution at the individual pixel level.
And importantly here, the CODEX and H&E images are coming from the same tissue,
so they're perfectly aligned. And this is orders of magnitude
larger than the data sets that we used in previous work from our
group, where we were able to
also do some of these imputations, but it was done on a much more limited set.
So leveraging this
large scale paired data set,
we developed ROSI, and here's sort of a brief overview of how it works.
So it takes input, the standard H&E images, and the
algorithm will first
crop those images into these individual patches.
Each patch will be 128 by 128 pixels.
And then we have a deep learning model that takes that patch, right, and then try
to predict and to impute the proteomics
profiles for each of these 50 or more biomarkers
at a much smaller, higher resolution of eight by eight
pixels. And the benefit of doing this is that this
enables the model to be able to capture information from a broader,
larger context in order to predict and impute the
biomarkers at a smaller window. And we showed in our paper that this
is a more effective approach.
And after that imputation, then the algorithm would take these
imputed eight by eight patches and stitch them all back
together into this whole slide level,
generated spatial proteomic image.
That's the in silico CODEX output from the ROSI
algorithm. This in silico CODEX then will be perfectly
aligned with the original H&E sample.
So with this approach, ROSI is able to predict in
silico CODEX for up to 50 different biomarkers.
So here's an example demonstration where we have these two H&E images
that were given as input into the algorithm.
And in the second column, I show the generated
in silico data that's imputed
by ROSI algorithm. And this can take maybe
less than $1,
less than an hour of time. A few minutes.
And the third column corresponds to where we took multiple days and
thousands of dollars to perform the actual experiment to do this CODEX
multiplex immunofluorescent imaging.
And comparing the ROSI output with the experimental outcome, which is the ground
truth, we can see that the ROSI output actually captures a lot of the
key structures and cell types as you do from the actual
experiments. And this is orders of magnitude, I think,
over 1,000 times faster and cheaper.
And in order to show that the results are quite representative across different
samples, what I'm showing here is actually the different
percentiles of different input
histology H&E images, where we rank
these different images by the Pearson correlation between
their imputed
CODEX with the actual experimentally measured CODEX.
So 99th percentile corresponds to the samples where the ROSI performed
better, and the 25th percentile corresponds to samples where our
algorithm performed relatively worse.
And what we can see here is that even if we look at the medium sample or the 25th
sample where the algorithm performed relatively worse, the output
from the in silico CODEX actually still matches a lot of the fine grain
structures that you see from the actual spatial CODEX measurements.
So this gives us more confidence that the algorithm can be quite
reliable. We also perform additional assessments
on data on H&E images from other locations.
So here are data from three different external sites, and here the ROSI algorithm
is also able to impute and generate some of these fine grain
structures that we saw in these out-of-distribution external validation
sites.
And one benefit and one application of this approach was in silico
CODEX of ROSI,
is that we can actually then infer more granular tissue
structures directly from the H&E images.
So here we're looking at three common kinds of tissue structures.
So in dark blue, it's the stroma, light blue is the more
tumor-like epithelium, and orange captures these more endothelium
structures.
And on the first column are the ground truth that we get from
when we actually do the expensive spatial proteomics
experimental measurements. We can capture these structures
very accurately.And the second column corresponds to if we use
Rosie to first impute the spatial proteomics and then do the
same kind of segmentations. We can see here we often capture very similar,
very precise imputed structures compared to the ground truth.
We also did a comparison where we took the original H&E image itself
and extract morphology features from the H&E image, and then trained
a deep learning model to directly predict these structures from the
H&E image morphologies, and that actually performed much worse.
So I think this is kind of an interesting comparison that demonstrates the benefit
of this Rosie approach to first impute the high
multiplex proteomics structures and then use those proteomics information then
to classify the different tissue structures.
So that ends up being richer and more robust than directly trying to
classify the tissue structures from
the morphology information itself.
And then finally, one of the benefits of Rosie is that it's really able to make
these imputations at a single pixel resolution,
which corresponds to around 25 microns.
So this enables the algorithm then to capture a lot of the
sub-single-cell resolution,
spatial structures of different proteins.
So this enables richer kinds of sub-single-cell or subcellular
analysis.
So just to summarize, so with Rosie, we demonstrate
that from H&E images, we can actually use AI to
infer protein expressions, cell types, structures
that typically required much more expensive multiplex
immunofluorescent imaging assays.
And this demonstrates the power and the promise of AI to help
us to bridge the gap between these more common and routinely available
assays and these much more experimental research-level
assays. And all of this can help us to enable
precision pathology.
So with Rosie, we see how with these kind of generative AI approaches, we can
enable us to make these spatial omics information more broadly
accessible by imputing them from H&E images.
In the second part, I want to highlight some examples of how we can then take
these kinds of single-cell and spatial omics assays and help us
with therapeutic developments.
In a recent work, we created what we call a virtual biotech,
which is a large organization of different AI agents that can help us with
drug discovery and development.
In this virtual biotech, it's a team of tens of thousands of AI agents,
which is led by a chief scientist officer, or CSO agent, and
working under the CSO agent, we have these different divisions, which
corresponds to the standard cross-functional divisions of a
typical drug discovery organization.
So, for example, we have a division of agents that focuses on target
identification, another division of agents that look at safety,
clinical developments, and so on.
All of these divisions are operationalized by teams of AI agents
with different specializations for
specialized roles. For example, under the target ID division, we
actually have an AI agent who specializes in doing single-cell
analysis, another agent that's very good at doing all the statistical genetics
analysis, and also agents that specialize in doing these more spatial
analysis.
And behind the scenes, to enable these agents to
carry this very in-depth analysis, we created a
universe of different resources and tools that enables
agents then to do analysis from the raw data.
So this corresponds to hundreds of different MCPs that we've collected.
So, for example, we have created MCP so that enables the agents to
directly access and download single-cell atlas data that are
relevant for their analysis. They can also access all of these different histology
H&E images
as well as data from genetics, from clinical trials, and from chemistry.
And the way that all of this work together is that
the user might have a specific query, and the query could be,
"Help me develop a therapeutic strategy for a particular kind
of disease target," for example. And then the CSO agent
would take that query and work with his chief of staff to come up with
a plan for the analysis. And then it would delegate that plan to the
different divisions of agents. All these agents then would proceed
in parallel. Maybe one agent will look at the histology images, another agent will
look at the genetics data. They can do all of these analysis in parallel.
We have a reviewer agent that reviews all of these intermediate results.
And then finally, all of these results will be synthesized by the CSO agent, then
presented back to the human user.
So I want to illustrate then a case study to demonstrate the
workings of this virtual biotech.
So a specific question we asked the biotech
agents is to help us to design therapeutic strategies for
CD276, also called B7H3, as a target in lung
cancer.
So this is a transmembrane checkpoint inhibitor
protein, which has emerged in recent years as a very exciting
target.
So the first thing that the virtual biotech agent did is that it started to look at
some genetics evidence
and actually found that there's really not very strong genetic evidence around this
target. But then the agents reasoned that that's okay
because this is a target that's more relevant in tumor cells, whereas a lot of the
genetics is looking at the germline mutations.
So then the agents pivoted and decided to look at single-cell data.
So it first pulled
single-cell data from different cell atlases from tissues that are relevant to lung
cancer.
And by analyzing those single-cell data, it found that this
target is particularly highly expressed in tumor-associated
fibroblastsRight? And based on that, the agents
came up with a hypothesis that
perhaps these tumor-associated fibroblasts are expressing this
checkpoint inhibitor, which then has the effect of suppressing the
immune response in their surrounding cells.
So to test that hypothesis, the agent next decided to perform a
cell-cell communication analysis.
By analyzing receptor ligand pairs, the agent actually found that
indeed, these tumor-associated fibroblasts have a lot of
communications with all the different major immune cell types.
But here is where the agent reasons that, okay, to really confirm
that in cell-cell communication, this will be really
useful to actually analyze spatial data to really sort of be able to
visualize these patterns of these
immune-suppressing effects.
And this is where the spatial analysis becomes really useful.
So to do this, the agent actually found and downloaded
these spatial transcriptomic datasets
from Visium.
And by analyzing this dataset, the agents actually showed
that indeed in areas where
these fibroblasts are expressing this P7H3
protein, the surrounding neighborhoods are systematically
depleted of different immune cell types.
So there's quite a significant effect.
So this actually really supports the agent's hypothesis
that indeed that these fibroblasts are expressing this target,
and then which has the effect of suppressing the immune response in their
neighborhoods.
And then finally, the agents are able to then connect all of this together with
human clinical cohorts.
So we look at cohorts of patients from lung cancer that are
expressing this target either at a high level or a low level.
And so by stratifying this target expression, the agents actually
found that patient cohorts that express these targets
highly are less responsive to different treatments, as
measured both in terms of overall survival and also disease-specific
survival.
So all of these different pieces of evidence come together, and it's all conducted
autonomously by the AI agents in the virtual biotech to form
a mechanistic story of how this target
in fibroblasts may have this kind of immune-suppressing effects, which
then leads to worse outcomes for patients.
Now, based on all of that information and by analyzing all of that data, especially
the spatial omics data, the agents actually then designed a
therapeutic strategy for CD276 in lung cancer.
So from its analysis, the agent said, "Okay, I recommend designing an
antibody-drug conjugate, or ADC, or a monoclonal antibody
that's targeting CD276." And this
antibody then will be linked to a chemotherapy payload,
DXd.
And this
is designed and proposed by the agents based on information available to it
before January 2025.
And what's really quite interesting is that several months later, in
August 2025, we have
the FDA had actually approved--
gave a breakthrough designation to Merck.
So Merck had actually independently converged onto a similar
strategy of ADC with the same antibody
targeting CD276. It's actually linked to the same chemotherapy
payload, DXd, and they showed quite promising results, which received
this breakthrough designation from the FDA.
I think this provides actually a very nice and exciting external independent
validation for how a therapeutic strategy from the agents which
came from leveraging all of these single-cell spatial analysis
can then be
supported by
clinical study results from third parties.
So another thing that the agent did more broadly that's
quite exciting is it has helped us to curate data from all these
different clinical trials.
So here we ask the agents to basically curate clinical trial outcomes
because all of these clinical trials are registered, but often the outcomes of what
happened in these clinical trials are spread out across different
sources, different papers, press releases, sometimes company
websites.
It will be very useful if we have a centralized database where all these clinical
trial informations are collected.
So here the virtual biotech spun out thirty-seven thousand clinical trial
agents. Each agent is responsible for annotating the outcomes
of one trial. So that agent then will go
for that trial to read all the things that happened in that trial and
look up all the papers, the news articles, websites
to find out what are all the endpoints and what happened to the endpoints.
If the trial had stopped, why did it stop?
Are there any side effects, adverse events, and so on.
So this creates a really nicely curated database of clinical trial
outcomes for fifty-six thousand trials.
And then based on that, we ask the agent, so can you find single-cell features
that's based on these molecular features that are actually strongly predictive of
clinical trial success? So that would be if we have features that can
predict trial success, then that's often a holy grail for the drug
development because then it can help them to prioritize different drug targets.
So here the agents actually came up with two interesting single-cell features
based on single-cell
transcriptomics information. The first is that the agent proposed
this tau cell type specificity score, which measures if you look at the
drug target, how selective is the expression of that drug target across different
cell types. The second feature measures the bimodality,
basically how on and off is that drug target across different
cell types.The agents reasoned that if this drug target
has a very distinct on/off switch pattern, then it's more controllable
and potentially a better drug target.
And then by collecting these single-cell molecular features with actual
clinical trial outcomes, the agent found that indeed,
drug targets that have these more cell
type-specific expressions are 48% more
likely to reach market, right? And overall, if we look at both
the tau score and the bimodality score, they're highly correlated
with better outcomes across phase two, phase three, phase four.
They're associated with better
chances of meeting the clinical
primary and secondary endpoints, and these trials are less likely to be
withdrawn for various reasons. So I think this is quite
exciting, in particular because these single-cell
features are actually orthogonal to genetic features.
So people have known for some time that drug targets with genetic evidence are more
likely to be successful. And here the agents actually showed that
even among drug targets that have no genetic support,
if they do have these single-cell evidence supporting it, then those are more
likely to be successful.
So I think this is an example of how these agents then can help to integrate
single-cell data and then help us to
prioritize different drug targets.
So I'll just stop here. I hope to show these two examples
illustrate how this generative and agentic AI
can both enable
spatial omics analysis and also leverage this analysis to help us
to improve our therapeutic developments.
I want to especially thank Eric Wu, who led the ROSI work, and
Harrison Jiang, who led the virtual biotech work.
Thank you very much for your time.
Okay, I'm just
timing myself.
Awesome. So I think the most
useful agent that we can possibly build
today would be a very simple agent, actually,
that just signs data-sharing agreements between
institutes. Just imagine that we can cut the
half a year nonsense lawyering up of
data-sharing agreements by two agents
that do that in one day. That would be a tremendous contribution to
cancer research. Okay. So
back to spatial
biology. I want to talk about towards fast and
accessible precision oncology, and I'll aim to do it in
20 minutes so we'll have time for discussion.
So these are my disclosures, and
this is published stuff that I
will not talk about, and I just want to explain
what is this dividing line.
So in this published work, my lab over the
last two or three years have developed
ways to infer molecular omics data bulk,
gene expression, methylation, what have you,
directly from the whole slide images and
then use that for clinical translational
applications. So, for example, when we infer
transcriptomics, we showed that we can use the
inferred bulk transcriptomics from the whole slide
images to infer patient survival and response
almost at the level that you could do from the
sequencing data.
And when we infer methylation, we focused on brain tumors
where methylation is used-- Sequencing
methylation is used as the gold standard for
classifying brain tumors at a high resolution.
We have shown
that we can actually do that at a level that is
practically indistinguishable from the sequence methylation.
We can do it from the inferred methylation.
And you can see publications from different years
just to show you that in a span of one
year or one year and a half, we can double and
triple the accuracy of the clinical
value that we can bring to the patients on the same tasks.
And that's whole bulk inference clinical
application from whole slide images.
And the reason that we can triple, quadruple
our accuracy is because we are
leaning on the advancements from other groups that are
building better and better foundation
models, and we also have better biological insights
and clinical insights and so on. But what I want to focus
today is on these types of
analysis where we move from inferring
bulk molecular data from the whole slides to
inferring spatial omics data
as Mingyao has shown so
nicely. And our goal is to
learn to teach the machines to learn to
infer spatial expression, spatial proteomics
at
any spot in the tumor, at any cell in the tumor,
automatically segment and annotate the
cells, and use that to define
and study and validate a conceptually
new typeOf clinical survival and response
biomarkers that are spatially grounded.
And that's a whole new arena that requires a lot
of thought and a lot to study, and
we are just making our first steps,
but I think that in the next two, three years, it will be
transformative and hopefully, reach the
clinic sometime soon.
So the first thing that I want to share with you is
this paper, which is to appear soon, which has been
led by Eldad Schulman and Emma Campanolo from my lab with
many collaborators, where we
taught machines to learn
visium data in breast cancer by training on visium
data.
And we then created maps,
inferred spatial visium maps of the
whole breast cancer TCGA compendium, which is
1,100 patient samples at a
detailed spatial resolution,
and
then we used that to characterize the TME
of these patients, find survival predictions, treatment response
predictions, and so on. And just to show you a bit
on that before I move to the really unpublished
data. So you can see here overall we can
robustly predict about 4,000 genes.
Here you can see the histograms of the
correlations between the measured and inferred genes across
the spots in each sample, and
we did extensive validations, and we can predict
about 4,000 genes. The spatial transcriptomics
of visium of 4,000 genes. So out of the 10 or
15,000, we can predict only 4,000.
But it's important to notice that these are not random genes.
These are highly enriched in the main cancer
hallmark pathways. It's interesting when you think about it, with
the inferable predictable genes,
that those are evident from the slides are actually those
that are belonging to the cancer drivers and hallmarks.
And as you know, one picture is worth a thousand words.
Here are three key genes in breast cancer,
ELK2, KI67, and MYC. And on the left
side of each pair, these are samples from patients.
This is the measured spatial visium transcriptomics, and this is the
inferred. Here is another patient sample, the measured and
the inferred, and so on. And you can look at it, each of you,
and get a sense of
how good it is by yourself. And of course, we are not
perfect, but you can form your own impression.
And just to show one last slide from that
topic because I really want to
leave ample time for discussion. So this
is
two AUC curves, patient survival.
This is a study, Samut et al. by Carlos Caldas' group,
published in "Nature" about two and a half years ago,
where for each breast cancer patient,
they
did whole exome sequencing, RNA sequencing.
They also built direct predictors from the whole slide images and also
from the clinical and lab data. And on the
green AUC curves is what they could get, actually, what
they publish in the "Nature" paper for these patients,
the AUCs for the
response to treatments, chemotherapy or chemotherapy and trastuzumab.
And the blue is what we do. So the green is
for about $10,000 per patient and many weeks of
work, and the purple is what we do just from the
image by spatial characterization of the tumor
microenvironment, and you can see for yourselves.
But where I want to take you now is to
completely new and unpublished data, where we are
performing an attempt to infer
spatial transcriptomics to automatically segment
each cell, infer its spatial transcriptomics on a
slide,
and then--
Oh, sorry. Before that, I want to take you to
a foray where we infer spatial tumor
hotness. So what is tumor hotness?
We have a paper on bioRxiv
where we found a signature of
the tumor immune activation. Again,
one number for each slide, okay? And that's
the tumor hotness, okay? And we
find that this one scholar,
the tumor hotness, across many different
cancer types, this one scholar is
actually,
in our hands, the best predictor that we have of
checkpoint immunotherapy response across different
cancer types, different clinical trials.
We never trained on them. So we just look at the
slide, we estimate the tumor hotness, one scholar
from zero to one, and this is the kinds of AUCs and
odds ratios you get. So the mean odds
ratio that you get across different test cohorts
is five. Well, if you aim to build a direct
predictor without automatically inferring this
hotness signature and so on, you get
much, much worse results. So it shows you
the power of inferring molecular data.
But this was, again, one hotness scholar,
okay?For a whole slide.
But we went on, and this is available on BioRxiv, and
we'll soon submit it. But we went
further, and we built, and when I say we, it's Tai
Huang, we built
predictors of the tumor immune
activation, the tumor hotness at each
spot on the H&E. So it's a pan-cancer predictor
trained on 12 cancer types and 208 slides
and so on. And it achieves accuracies of larger
than 0.8 in inferring the tumor immune
activation in its spot. And if you think about it, it
opens very interesting opportunities to
systematically study the true cellular
modulators of
tumor hotness. And here again, you can see some pictures,
and you can see a head and neck image, the H&E slide.
This is the matching Visium slide.
So since we have the hotness signature, we can infer
the signature on the measured H&E.
We call that the actual spatial hotness.
And here is the totally inferred hotness just from the
H&E slide. And you can see, again,
you form your own impression from these few examples on
how accurate or inaccurate we are.
And just to show you that, so we have taken, since this is a
pan-cancer hotness predictor, okay, so we take the
good old TCGA data. And, as
you know, thousands of papers have built
survival,
Cox survival
predictors based on the measured RNA.
So that invests thousands of dollars in the bulk to do
it for each patient and what have you.
And here you can see
how actually, quite surprisingly, the level of
immune hotness, one scholar has
inferred from this spatial analysis and
summed up, I'm not going into the details, actually,
the spatial hotness of a tumor in most of the different tumor
types is much better predictor of patient
survival than the RNA sequence data, the
thousands of papers that use that.
Okay, so now I'm coming to our efforts to
develop these spatial
predictors at the single cell, and I'll show you
ongoing work in inferring Visium
HD, inferring Codex data, and annotating
cells based on these inferences.
So again, one picture,
just to give you an idea. This is a colon cancer data set or
no colon, published last year in "Nature Genetics."
Here is the original picture, the slide, the Visium HD of
the authors, and you can see the different cell types that
the authors have annotated. And here is the
inferred
annotations of the cells based on the inferred Visium
data. This costs $10,000, and you have to wait
weeks. This, you buy my fellows a cup of coffee, and you
get it the next day. And you can decide where to invest your
money,
right? It's a free country still.
And this is another slide. This is a normal
colon. And you can see we are not perfect,
right? Even my fellows are not perfect.
So you can see here there is a measured, annotated
something, red cell something, and we miss it here
and so on. And if you look carefully in this slide, you can
see that there is some false positive made.
I don't see them, but trust me. So we make
mistakes, and we are not perfect in both.
And now I want to take you to predicting Codex data, what
James has shown,
except that he's not here, so I can say, but much better.
Okay. That's the price of staying at home.
So
this is a pan-cancer
Codex predictor. And you can see on the Y-axis,
the correlation between the measured and inferred
Codex level of each biomarker
across each individual cell.
And these are the top ones. There's other ones that I'm not showing
that we do less. But overall, we do mean
correlations of 0.4 to 0.6, depending on
the indication. These are results in
cross-validation in three cancer types on which we trained,
but then we have an ensemble pan-cancer predictor.
And these are actually test results on independent data sets.
So you can pick your favorite markers, and again,
you can see what one can do. So again, just to quickly
show, here is, let's say you're interested in PD-L1 or
CD833. Here is the original H&E. Here is the measured
matching sample of measured PD-L1, and here is the inferred
PD-L1 in that sample. And here is CD48,
the H&E, the measured CD48, and the inferred
CD48. And this is for two other markers, CD45,
for example, and KI67. And these are not
particularly good examples. These are really
typical examples, and you can see the overall correlations.
And based on thatYou can now, since we segment the
cells and we have the
markers inferred and so on, we can annotate the cells.
We can't do it yet at a very high resolution.
We can do it on a resolution of five or six cell types, and
that still
isn't as great as we should. But you can imagine that we
can infer not also the
markers, we can having
predictors of Visium HD or Xenium HD,
we can combine predictors. So we are going to improve
that in the near future very much. But even so,
we can infer tumor cells very accurately and
other cell types,
quite interesting. And I'll show you the importance and
application of that. And what is important, as
Mingyao mentioned, we have ways to estimate the confidence
of our predictions. So if we are ready to give up and
leave out some of the cells and focus on the more
confident cells, then we can have very confident
predictors. As I always tell my fellows, less is more.
So just to show you, since we can predict cancer cells so
accurately and annotate them,
automatically, you give us a slide and we
pinpoint with 97% accuracy or
more every tumor cell on the slide.
Just imagine that we put it on the pathologist's
desktop. He puts on a slide, immediately gets
all the tumor cells or what have you.
So what can you do
now the dream is happening? Okay. You
can annotate confidently a large subset of the
cells which you segment in each slide, just the H&E
in each tumor. So you can now start to
systematically look for all the
triads, quadruples, quantiples-- I don't know, my English is
not good enough. All the spatial relations between
different cell types and associate them, and that's what
important, with patient survival and treatment
response, because you can apply to large cohorts
of hundreds of thousands of patients.
All you need is love.
All you need is the H&E slides,
right?
So that's what, in a study led by Amos
Temer and Tai Huang, they can systematically
scan, this is ongoing work, all the triads.
Very interestingly, we see that this is in breast
cancer, that triads that involve lymphocytes and
endothelial cells, lymphocytes emigrating from
vascular
blood vessels and so on, are highly
associated with either increased
hazard ratios in survival in breast cancer or decreased
ones. So actually, the lymphocyte endothelial
is associated with a decreased hazard ratio.
And when you look at
triads that are associated in chemotherapy and trastuzumab
response, you find again that that
triad of lymphocytes and endothelial cells
is associated with this five
times odds ratio. This is clinically very
meaningful, if ever validated, of patients' response to
trastuzumab. So in summary, to keep in time,
we are developing a comprehensive suit of AI predictors
at the single cell, at the Visium, at the transcriptomic level, at the bulk
level, at the transcriptomic level, and at the single-cell level that
predicts anything you want to know about what's
happening in your slides. It's really a dream
come true that is unfolding as we do it.
And that gives rise to the possibility to
questions that I couldn't think we could study one or two years ago.
What are the mediators of tumor hotness and tumor immune
activation at the cellular level?
And a new type of spatially grounded biomarkers,
and
possibly a way to democratize precision oncology to really
transform its accessibility to patients in
many underserved regions in our nation and across the
world. In principle, it could be developed in other disorders.
And just at 1:00 pm, I was asked by the
editors of Cancer Discovery, you can scan
this thing, and at 1:00 pm, they said they
published a paper, a prospective paper that we wrote in Cancer
Discovery that
further elaborates and describes this vision, which is close to my heart,
of democratizing
precision oncology. This is
our lab from one or two years ago. This is my close friend, Ken
Aldape,
who was a partner in crime for all the methylation and brain
work, and many of our fellows. This is actually the garden in our house,
and now you may understand why I'm not moving in St.
Louis and staying in Bethesda.
So, thank you all so much. And
Mingyao, would you like to join me, please, to answer questions?
And I think there are questions on the right.
And anyone can also ask us. So, thank you so much.
We have 12 minutes. So
I am not sure I know how to operate
thatSo let's start from questions for the audience.
Is that okay? Anyone wants to ask?
Everyone is running away on the most interesting-- Because you
need to go to other places. And yes, please.
Yes.
Hi, Eitan.
Hey.
Fantastic work as always.
And I promised I would try to ask you a question that would
bring on some more discussion and perhaps be a little controversial.
So when we think about the evolution of tumors under
therapeutic pressure,
we have to sometimes disregard some of
the
preconceived assumptions about established gene
networks. That certain patterns of gene upregulation and
downregulation that are important in the establishment of a tumor are
likely going to change under therapeutic pressure.
In your spatial prediction models, how do you
account for the
likely heterogeneity and perturbation of
predicted gene expression based on
morphology when you've trained on a lot of untreated samples?
Thank you so much. Mingqiao, would you like to answer, please?
Or you want me or whatever. Please.
I
can try to answer, but I don't think I have a good solution for that, because
as you can see in my training data, I don't have patients that
have response to a therapy. So
I think
if you don't have the
patient to have a response directly measured, I think the information you
learn is also limited.
As I mentioned in my Aurora work,
we see that the dynamic range is a substantial variable from one person
to the other. I think the same thing is true when a person is
undergoing a therapy. Maybe the dynamic range is different.
So if we have some type of training data available, I
think that the model should be able to see that.
But right now, if we don't have such training data, I think the ability to do that
will be limited. But that is my guess. I don't really know.
Right. And I think that, just as a quick follow-up, and then I'll step
down, I would be interested in understanding or
predicting mechanisms of resistance.
And I think that's a challenge right now with any
morphology-based approach because there's a near infinite
combination of interactions between
tissue acquired and whatever spatial data you have
available and, of course, the therapies that are being tested.
I feel like this is a very big challenge for our field, and I'm looking forward to
great advances in this. And I'm curious whether you have any other thoughts on this
very challenging issue.
I-
Go ahead.
Okay. I can answer this question because I thought a lot about this.
I don't think virtual prediction is able to solve everything.
The only purpose, for me at least, why I do virtual prediction is I
wanted to generate a virtual population cohort so that I can identify
the important tissue regions for us to focus on.
Because it's just not possible to generate the real spatial omics data for
thousands of patients. However, we can use the virtual prediction as a start
to localize which regions in the tissues are really
important. And once we localize the proxy of the
regions, we can conduct the real spatial omics experiment and
investigate what is really going on.
That is a method about doing virtual prediction.
Yeah.
Please. Thank you so much, Adam. Please.
Hello. It's just a general question.
So you showed that you did the enrichment analysis on the high
correlation genes, but did you do the enrichment analysis on the
low correlation genes as well? So which genes are badly predicted in
general?
All the genes which are not well predicted.
Very good.
No, I mean by default, we point to the
main hallmarks, cancer hallmarks, that are well-predicted,
but no. But I'll tell you what.
There's some disappointing news here because a
lot of the important immune genes that we would have
loved to see in the predicted pathways are not
necessarily inferable at the spatial
resolution. And that is because they don't have a
priori, a spatial variation, a large spatial
variation. So think of the extreme case.
If a gene has zero spatial variation,
you cannot predict it. There's nothing to predict.
There's no variation for the machines to predict upon.
So there is no systematic comparison there then?
It's like there is specific pathways that would be well predicted.
For example, G2M checkpoint, like with the KI67, it's pretty well
predicted. But let's say, I don't know, some other pathway like
ME targets?
So we know what is predictable and what is not, and that's the
important thing, okay? Know your limitations, know where you are good,
and work with that.
Yeah.
Think positive.
Yeah. And just one suggestion, too.
I would just reconsider the "path to hotness" name because I just
Google and I'm afraid my IT team will ping me
back.
You afraid what? Sorry.
So I Google "path to hotness" on Google.
Yes.
Google corrected for other stuff.
Google corrected for?
Like, just corrected. Like, it spelled it all other things.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you so much. Yep. Thank you.
Hey, how's it going? Kevin Boehm from Sloan Kettering. Great talks.
My question is along the same lines around, I understand that
you can identify cancer hallmarks, but to what extent can you identify subclonal
determining phenotypic states?
Do you want to answer, Mingqiao?Please.
I don't think I can answer this question.
Okay. So
I do not know the answer. That remains to be studied.
I think to understand the spatial
organization of subclonal, you really need to be able to
infer sequencing data on a spatial level,
mutations, copy numbers, what have you.
You can do it from spatial expression to some extent, but I'm not a
big believer. So I think it's a very important question,
but I don't think yet we have the means to answer it.
Sweet. Thanks.
Yeah.
Jerry Lee from NCI. Nice to see you.
That's a great talk. But the question is for Dr. Li.
I may miss this. My question's about the
models you developed. Were you able to
distinguish different tumor cell
populations
with different genetic or epigenetic background
without additional training data?
So currently, the model is not able to distinguish that
because, as you have seen in my talk, not all of the training data are obtained
from spatial transcriptomics. So I do not have information on the
epigenetic profiles. But all of the prediction models, I think, are very
generic in nature. If we have spatial omics data that
have the epigenetic information, we can do such training as
well. So my lab has been collaborating with Dr.
Yanxiang Dong at Penn, and Dr. Dong is an expert in
developing spatial epigenetic technologies.
And we have been applying our virtual prediction models to his
datasets, and it works equally well.
So we were able to computationally predict chromatin accessibility and
epigenetic marks. But it's not at the population scale because the
training data we have is still very limited at this point.
Thanks.
Thank you. If there's not, maybe we can still figure
out. We have three minutes to answer questions.
Where do I see the questions?
They should be right on the monitor.
But it's not. Oh, these
are the questions. Oh my God, so many questions.
Oh, God.
Oh, here is something for you
because I see TLSs.
Oh, okay.
I'm saved.
So how do you know the detected aggregate of B and
the T cells is TLS without IHC and
IF for validation on the same sample?
That is a good question. I don't think the
calling of a TLS is accurate. I think a better name for it should
be a lymphoid aggregate.
That's another question.
Or that's James?
That is for me.
Okay.
COSY. So what is the resolution in map at which
COSY operates? The resolution is eight micron.
It's close to a single-cell resolution.
Next one is also for me.
Yes, go ahead.
Can you extend your analysis to set pathological
samples such as fine nodule
aspirates and bone marrow peripheral
smears?
I have not tried that, so I don't have an answer for that question because I don't
have access to this type of data.
Did you consider these checkpoints?
I have not.
So yeah, we focused on PD-1, PD-L1, and then there is a question,
and I think this will be the last one.
Which spatial transcriptomic platforms is better
to make an AI model? Would you like to?
So I have experience working with all sorts of spatial omics platforms.
And among all of the platforms I have tried so far, I prefer Xenium the best.
I second that.
You second that? Yeah.
I second that, and I just want to say that now
10x has released an all-gene Xenium
platform, which I think should be amazing, and I'm
nothing with 10x or anything,
which I think could be extremely helpful.
But in general, we found Xenium 5,000 to be
a very powerful platform, and now with this
new whole gene transcriptomic Xenium,
that could be transformative. You want to see if there's any other question?
I think there's one question for you, Doctor.
Oh, for me?
Yeah.
Okay.
How is the tumor hotness quantity
defined?
Okay.
The tumor hotness or the tumor immune activation, we didn't invent the
term hotness. Everyone talks about hot and cold tumors in the literature,
right? So
it's inferred by a level of enrichment of
some immune activation signature, which we derived, and
it's in this bio RV paper, and I
didn't have time to explain. And the level of enrichment
is normalized and calibrated to a scholar value between
zero and one. Yes, please.
Hi.
Last question.
So,
just one comment and question. I think you said that
predicting spatial expressions from H&E is cheaper
than doing molecular testing, but then on the other end, to
produce that data, to even model that further-
To produce that data?
Produce that data-
Yeah
... using Xenium and Visium, it requires a lot of cost structure
in place, funding, et cetera.
How do you anticipate this whole technology
of capturing the spatial transcriptomics or proteomics, first using
Xenium or Visium, and then making models on top
of it,
being clinically translated in a
cheaper way compared to just doing molecular testing?
No, that's the whole idea, right? You only generate this
training data once in principle. Well, you generate two
free training data sets because you want to test and validate it, but then
you're good to go for eternity just from the H&E slides.
That's the whole point.
But would you be okay with just having it trained
once and not
trained again?
That's okay.
And-
Of course, you can do that in a year or two or whatever,
and it may be in different ethnic groups and things like that,
but that's very cheap. You do it just once, and then you can
run on thousands or ten thousands or whatever of
patient slides, and you can get results in real-time with almost
zero cost. There's no question that if you can do it, it's
extremely valuable. We need to carefully understand the
different population, different scanning machines, prospectively,
whatever, how well we can do it. But if we can do it,
that's huge.
Right. So to scale the data to that level, to capture enough
heterogeneity in each and every aspect that you mentioned, that
requires a good amount of funding and-
Of course
... over the time it will pay off, but then how do we justify
that to
our community?
I think it's a no-brainer. The value is
tremendous. This is transformative.
I'm not bothered at all by the ability to justify it.
I'm just--
Carefully, we need to test how good it will work.
That's the thing. That we still need to study very carefully.
Okay. Thank you.
Oh, thank you. Last question, please.
Hi, this is Ray from Inside. Very nice talk.
So, I know when we're trying to train the AI model, we always make sure that the
sample has a very good QC.
But in the real clinical settings, so the sample QC is always at issue.
So I want to know, have you had an understanding how the QC can affect-
Yeah
... the accuracy or the prediction?
100%. I got you. I'm so sorry. Just because of the time.
Would you like to answer first, or you want me to pitch in?
Sure. I can answer this question because I thought a lot about that.
If you remember my slide on the ecosystem of where I try to build, we start from
QC of the pathology slides. That step is very
important.
And thank you so much, and I can only second and say that we
also developed
careful QC tools and measures. We show
it in our upcoming Path to Space paper, which is--
earlier versions are on bioRxiv, but the full version will come out in
cell, I don't know, in two months or something.
And if you look there, we have whole sections about
QC measures, both on the slide quality
scanning level and on the transcriptomics
level
and how they influence the quality
of the prediction.
Okay, so we did an in-depth study of that question.
Thank you so much because it's very important.
Thank you.
So in reality, when patient slides come in, we will
run QC and only if it's reasonable, we will aim
to make predictions. If not, we'll say, "Guys, we are sorry.
We can't trust our predictions on that and
just do the sequencing or what have you." Okay?
That's helpful. Thank you.
Thank you so much. Thank you everyone.
We are past the time and thanks to Dr.
Zhu
and yeah, Mingye